[Music]
what is happening there reject nation we
are here today to talk about something
that was brought to my attention
something that flew over my head
software looking and sounding a little
bit
gross overcoming some stuff we're
keeping the door open we got some cats
who are roaming around right now but
guys
spider-man no way home that's right
we're talking about that today and did
tom holland confirm that there is indeed
going to be a six member to round out
this sinister six if you go to
koijondro's channel he has the full
video there of the trailer release fan
event it's an hd it looks great it's the
best way to watch it it's not just a
plug for my friend it's a plug so you
can experience it the best and so a lot
of people were just doing videos on
their phone but there was one part here
and my friend aaron who was in our
spiderman no way home trailer reaction i
wanted to be involved pointed out this
very specific line that tom holland said
and i was like
interesting so i want to play for you
guys really fast and see what you guys
think and afterwards i got
three conclusions as to what he might be
saying here this movie isn't just the
culmination of my spider-man
era
we are villains coming from three
different universes
reprising their roles bringing them back
to life he says right there we have
villains coming from three different
universes so right now we know that we
got a villains coming from andrew
garfield's electro lizzie and then from
toby sandman doc ock and green goblin
the third universe is what what is the
third universe
that is the question and this could be a
big deal for people because not long ago
all the leakers scoopers you know who
all them are their hearing is just gonna
be five villains
not a sinister six but perhaps sony is
working their way towards a sinister six
movie let's talk about this we got three
to five theories and then other random
theories that we might come up with in
the middle of discussing this off the
dome today theory number one he could
just be talking about someone as simple
as mysterio for example or the vulture
or the vulture returning villains really
making it feel like a full culmination
could be scorpion because it could be
pulling from tom holland's spider-man
universe right i feel like mysterio will
make the most sense especially since
you're kicking this off with the events
of mysterio's death and how he ratted
out peter parker to the world and how he
brought the multiverse at least talk
with him there's the other possibility
i'm sure a lot of people are probably
getting that maybe it's venom
maybe it could be venom maybe it could
be morbius i don't really know
why they'd be there on top of that too
he's saying villain that's why i have a
hard time believing that because they
are anti-heroes in those movies yes they
are not full-fledged villains so what it
makes sense they'd be like we got to go
after spider-man right now so i'm
thinking maybe it has something to do
with that scene that they teased at the
very end when doctor strange was like i
can't stop it from coming through or
stop them from coming through they're
starting to come through eric vossen
knew rockstars was having some theories
as somehow that sequence could be
setting up mutants charles xavier's
rumored to be in dr strange's multiverse
madness but i don't really know what
villain from like the x-men world it
would be that would make any sense at
all for it to happen and then as i was
going through koi's video i saw people
talking about this quite a bit because
there's one very big possibility
that we haven't considered he might have
just said that without it meaning that
that we are bringing
three
movies together yeah without saying we
have the three spider-man in here maybe
he didn't mean that there are three
universe of a worthy of villains that
he's just talking about how they're
combining three universes in this one
movie and it happens to be bringing
villains over from a couple of them
because this is moments after he played
the trailer there's a lot of energy
there's a lot of momentum you're
speaking live sometimes you say things
and put your words in certain grammar
formation it may not have been the best
choice or worse than you got people like
us who are dissecting it
i first thought that like guys he might
have just been he might have just
misspoke but then i did go back to that
scene of doctor strange
so john who do you think he could be oh
boy it could be craven the hunter i i
kind of doubt that would happen he's
also maybe somebody who would have the
most sort of reason to go after
spider-man initially
spider-verse like the actual
spider-verse movie get kingpin in there
or somebody from netflix it'd be kingpin
coming through that's who's that's who's
dr strange can't stop from coming he's
so big he just can't look at this fat
bald guy's coming through so huge oh my
god
i mean unless they're gonna bring in a
universe that i haven't considered like
someone from dc or something like that
or do you think we're just overthinking
this i
i'm really torn because i can absolutely
see how we might just be overthinking
this and i mean even if there isn't a
prominent use of one of the holland
universe villains i mean there's got to
be at least mention of them or presence
felt
of their aftermath in this world somehow
but also given all the different reports
and things some of which have come true
i wouldn't discredit the possibility of
a surprise you know i mean there's a lot
of debates surrounding dr strange as
well some people think doctor strange is
acting 100 normal something doctor
strange is acting a little bit sus
perhaps a little bit villainous so maybe
there is something there but doctor
strange maybe he is strange supreme
maybe maybe it's something to do with
wanda since spiderman no way home is
segwaying into dr strange's multiverse
of madness theories going around that
wanda might be manipulating our little
doctor strange here i can see that
bottom line do you think he is
confirming or affirming that there is a
villain that we do not yet know about i
think that's a distinct possibility
because i mean you know they want to
tease us with like toby ninja and all
that stuff and they've been very upfront
and also they seem to have been the most
lacks about in the early lead up in
revealing these villains and so part of
me wonders if they are concealing some
kind of other villain surprise that will
either dwarf or really hyper accelerate
the threat of the villains we already
know about check this out it is mysterio
right
what it is mysterio
how do you know and everything with
sandman lizard and other spiderman all
just one giant illusion of serious casts
just to piss all you guys off yes yes
it's the elementals all over he's just
doing the exact exact same reviews
bigger
with a more recognizable ip
not a bad theory he's already shown that
he knows how to do illusions based on
the elements and whatnot and what do we
get with goblin explosions what do we
get with sandman sand what do we get
with electroelectricity
makes some sense now i'd be happy if
there is a sixth fill and unveiled maybe
neg does become hop goblin he definitely
should after mj falls the movie for that
yeah he goes screw this screw this on
the hobgoblin and then you know the
glider's just laying there he's like
it's time for me to shine
madame webb uh may transforms down at
the base of the tower she's like you
know what peter you're in way over your
head i gotta take control now
hey mysterio could be a great
explanation as to why the lizard got
punched so like you know you're doing an
illusion that big it's gonna be a little
glitchy right what is your final
conclusion i'm gonna put my money on
that especially again with the way the
official trailer the full second trailer
uh really rested most everything on look
at our five villains
and the prevalence of the term sinister
six i have to imagine that there's some
other thing they have up their sleeve
that they haven't even had us thinking
about because i feel like as much as
it's the worst kept secret in hollywood
i think they know and they are using
that intentionally toward their
advantage and i wouldn't be at all
surprised if they have a surprise threat
in the store all right guys well thanks
so much for being here what do you think
about his words what do you believe
subscribe click that notification bell
flip that like button say hi to jesus
and we'll catch you guys soon